my name is Pamela Graham for those of
you who don't know me I work here at
Columbia libraries as the director of
global studies and the director of the
Center for Human Rights documentation
and research and it's really a great
pleasure to be moderating this next
panel I had the good fortune of working
under jim's leadership for most of my
career and it's really an honor to have
the chance to participate in this
symposium so in this panel we're going
to follow a slightly different format
where we'll have more of a discussion
amongst the panelists around a set of
questions that that they've looked at
and considered and this panel lets us
really delve into issues we've heard
about already this morning and issues
were Jim throughout his career very
creatively and provocatively challenged
to think and think about issues of the
profession career development
recruitment and preparation for for
working in the libraries so I'm going to
go ahead and ask each panelist and I'm
going to take a seat here but I'm going
to ask each panelist to say a few words
of introduction and then we'll launch
into our questions so and if I could ask
you to start with the introductions so I
man Kenny I'm the feral university
librarian at Cornell University it's
been a distinct pleasure for me over the
last five or six years to work very
closely with Jim and my wonderful
colleagues here at Columbia I've been at
Cornell since 1987 and University
Librarian since 2008 hi I'm Krista
williford I'm the director of research
and assessment at the Council on library
and information resources the reason
that I'm here on this panel is because I
have been working well for the past ten
years with clear on its postdoctoral
fellowship program which many of you may
have heard heard of before and so that's
the perspective I bring to this panel
today I was a fellow between two
thousand four and two thousand six of
the very first two years and I suppose
I'm formally Farrell and now
domesticated because I subsequently got
my mlas from the University of
Washington in two thousand
hello good morning everyone my name is
Mark a puente i'm the director of
diversity and leadership programs at the
association of research libraries in
Washington DC I've been at ARL just a
little over six years and I believe the
reason that I've been called upon this
panel is uh well probably for numerous
reasons but one of which is I do manage
for diversity recruitment programs that
basically funds master of library and
information science studies to four
people from traditionally
underrepresented racial and ethnic
minority groups and then also for the
the work that we do on the leadership
side as well and I'm not eating candy I
am as well I'm a little under the
weather so please please excuse it the
occasional yeah well click there right
great thank you all and this is really a
really great group of people to address
the questions in front of us so I wanted
to begin with a very broad question that
can help lay the groundwork for the
discussion and that is to look at the
general question of what is the changing
nature of the work force in academic
libraries can you sketch out a bit for
us how you see this from the different
perspectives out of which you're all
working and and I'm going to ask you to
lead us off okay great so the panel
whatever happened to the library degree
requirement I'm not sure really that's
the question before us but rather what
constitutes librarian ship today
research libraries I'm most familiar
with them are really medium-sized
corporations and operating budgets in
the tens and I'd learned hundreds of
millions of dollars just as a business
doesn't just hire a sales force so to a
research library relies on a myriad of
skills and expertise one thing i do
believe about the future of the
librarian is that the day of the
generalist has passed we've witnessed
the rise of the functional specialist
those with particular expertise and
technology instructional design business
planning and the like with wonderful new
titles
no whoever is a digital even jealous
evangelist out there I'm jealous these
experts come with specialized training
and skill sets that are different from
those who entered our profession a
generation ago we also see I think a
resurgence in the Disciplinary expert as
distinctions in science and social
science the arts and the humanities are
key to engaging faculty and students but
despite this move there is some
resilience to the ml ml s or the ml is
eighty-four percent of all professional
staff at ARL institutions work hard
carrying MLS a decade ago and it's only
down two percent ten years later I know
mark will present some more beta about
the positions postings recently there is
a divide between a rising professional
staff and librarians and part of that
divide centers on the distinctions
between who are academics and who are
professionals at Cornell we have two big
buckets for academics in our
professional library in our library to
job families you either a librarian or
you're an archivist there are few
anomalies we have to research associates
who came in with those appointments and
to visiting scholars Terry Bellinger who
at Columbia founded rare book school and
African Bambaataa who is a founding hip
hop pioneer who has no BA our makeup at
Cornell a thirty one percent or academic
twenty-two percent are professional and
forty-seven percent our support staff
almost all the librarians have MLS's
less so for the archivists and but we're
just beginning to move away from
requiring the mls for some of the
library posts I see a future where our
professional staff at Cornell is
one-third functional experts one-third
disciplinary experts and a third
librarians
someone who brings information
management library skills to the table
one final point of interest we're seeing
a shift among the professional staff at
Cornell towards librarian posts
primarily I think because of the
academic status these posts convey I'm
of two minds about this are we trying to
make other experts shoehorn into too few
buckets or job families so why should a
lawyer have to be a librarian to have an
academic status or are we seeing a
redefinition of what it means to be a
librarian which has less and less to do
with the credentials that you bring to
the table and more to do with perhaps
the resilience of what librarianship is
all about I can't quite decide which
side of the fence I'm on in that one
first all right the postdoctoral
fellowship program has been bringing
recent PhDs into libraries since 2004
and we've a total of 116 recent phd's
brought into libraries over that time to
53 different host institutions so I
really have this kind of narrow focus
well at Brian broad at the same time on
on this specific program and on this
specific experience of the subject
experts most without the library degree
coming into to the library environment
to work for one to two years mostly two
years here's three general trends that
I've observed in the evolution of roles
and responsibilities of our fellows over
the history of the program and these are
interrelated the diversification of
subject domain expertise in the in the
library in 2004 the participants in our
program there were 11 of us and I think
maybe nine of us were literature
scholars and two were historians outro
and we had one information scientists as
well that we were very very humanities
focus in 2009 we incorporated our first
social scientists and 2010 our first
scientists and in 2012 with the support
of the Alfred P sloan Foundation and
subsequently the Andrew W mellon
Foundation we created fellowships for
data curation in the social sciences
sciences and specific areas of the
humanities so we've we've really seen a
kind of fluorescence of different sorts
of expertise being demanded by our
library hosts I'm we've also seen the
use of the subjects expertise in the
library become more integral to library
core services I think back when I was a
fellow there was the typical experience
was the fellow would be you know put
were up in Special Collections or kept
sort of that arm's length you know doing
research that would inform library
strategic decisions that might be made
later or working on specific projects
you know sort of contained but now we
have fellows who work on teams
delivering services direct working
directly with students and faculty we've
seen a change in the focus of our
fellowships from from more teaching
oriented to both teaching and research
working hand-in-hand and this comes of
course with the new emphasis on data
curation since the 2012 but we also have
seen our self funded fellowships be a
lot more data curation oriented and
digital humanities focused i would say
about three-quarters of our current
cohort of fellows either have a digital
humanities or data curation inflection
and they're in their role so there's a
three trends that I've observed mark if
you like I can pull up slides you have
great
so my slides are not nearly as sexy as
Greg's and but I have just a few I won't
i won't bore you if i can figure out how
to advance this okay sorry about that
there we go um so a few trends first of
all our organizations are hiring again
this is based on I'm getting feedback
here based on a very quick of it we're
fine a very quick scan of position
description postings on the ARL position
we call it the the jobs internships and
residency's database and as you can see
not surprisingly we looked at a small
sample i believe just over six percent
of those postings over the last five
years the good news is that we are on on
a positive trend which i think is great
if you look at the requirements of the
MLIS i'm not going to contradict dan
because i believe she's completely right
the sort of meta question here isn't the
state of the MLIS I think there are
implications for our workforce in terms
of how we create cultures that are going
to be inviting and allow people that
maybe do not have that particular that
specific credential and allowed them to
thrive and to collaborate with our
colleagues that that do but again before
you you call my mother and start
complaining about the lack of rigor in
this research project I this is just a
small snapshot I mean obviously we're
looking at just over about a hundred and
forty i believe institutions so just
beyond the 125 research libraries and
archives that are members of ARL and
again you know that and and that is a
tiny tiny sample of the well over 4,000
academic libraries in the united states
however this is what this looks like for
the the ml is required the green bar
that you have there we hand coded about
i believe it was just under 200 position
descriptions and this is what this looks
like or has looked like over the past
five years i think it's very interesting
the green bar specifically the language
that we coded as Emma
is required was only specifically MLS
required or equivalent foreign degree so
very very narrow narrow in scope in
terms of what we coated that way as you
can see MLAs are equivalent experience
so another advanced degree something to
that effect and a few years of relevant
professional experience that is in the
red bar and it is very interesting to
look at from 2010 to 2014 the rise in
positions that have no mention no formal
lis training being required 14.5 percent
in 2004 in our small sample we didn't
find any in 2010 so what do they look
like well let's see let's go back to
Noel is degree requirements these are
some of the the interesting titles may
be many higher level administrative
types of positions human resources
manager lots of the digital of the
digital work that we're doing and things
like marketing associates things like
that I found that to be very interesting
and if I can go back i also want just to
step further as we talked about bringing
people on into our organizations that
have high domain expertise deep subject
expertise which of our positions
required a PhD either required are
preferred and these are some of the
titles that that came out of that brief
analysis of those position descriptions
so i think you'll find it interesting
the other sort of you know framing of
this is that none of this reflects of
course who actually moved into those
positions and the credentials that they
had I mean on one side of it I happen to
time a former I'm a recovering music
librarian and so I know that community
and and and that movement very well the
head of the music library a PhD
preferred the person who moved in that
position did not have a PhD so I think
it's really interesting i would be i'm
sort of very and energized by this and i
want to take a deeper dive into more of
those trends past this and I would be
happy to share those data with you all
yep
great well shuffle back into position
here so so we're hearing that there are
these different trends and people with
different backgrounds that are occupying
the library so you know our next
question is to ask you how do you
envision creating the right environment
so people of these different backgrounds
King commingle and I'm also thinking
about what Carol mentioned earlier this
morning about creating the right kinds
of environments for for creative and
promising ideas so how would you how
would you envision the steps we should
take to create the right environment so
that people with diverse backgrounds can
conform this workforce and Kristin I'm
gonna have you start off this room I'm
happy to do that I am I'll just say for
things that about what makes our
fellowships successful we've had 116
fellowships as I've said not all of them
have been successful but the ones that
have been successful I think all these
things are true there's regular
structured contact with supervisors and
closest colleagues we have what we call
a boot camp experience a common
experience that kicks off the fellowship
program and for the last several years
we've brought these supervisors into
that experience and you know stress the
importance of working with the fellows
regularly on a day-to-day basis and the
sort of special concerns that fellow's
might have about you know subsequent
career development that kind of thing
and there there are all these great
intentions but that there isn't always
this follow through and and we have seen
fellowship sort of fall apart without
this regular structured contact a clear
definition of rolls without being
inflexible that's a really important
balance to strike for our fellows one of
our supervisors said something really
interesting in a recent report about her
fellow she was talking about how well
the fellow could operate in ambiguity
even while
racing a delivery oriented mindset you
know that's the kind of flexibility you
need for a person to like that to grow
and be productive in this kind of role
support for professional development is
the third thing and we've seen a great
divide between institutions that provide
a lot of support for our fellows to go
to conferences to pursue independent
research to you know get academic credit
for some of the work that they're doing
and in other institutions that feel like
that's not really you know what we in
the library do and and there's
definitely a difference in satisfaction
for our fellows and and I think for all
academic librarians this is also true
better professional development makes it
more satisfied and unproductive
librarian and finally and this is sort
of the personal characteristics of the
fellows that we find to be more
successful those are the fellows with a
broad intellectual curiosity and
appreciation for the expertise of others
now when we talk about the shortcomings
of the MLIS degree to produce great
librarians I think you can point you
know those same fingers at our PhD
programs so our fellows who you know
come into the library have been very
very strictly focused on their area of
expertise and it's an adjustment for
them to take a step back and embrace a
broader view and be able to transition
comfortably between the role of leader
in one context in the role of learner
and another and that that kind of person
is the kind of person we strive to
attract to the fellowship and that kind
of person I think is more successful in
libraries in general war and that sums
it up pretty well I was I was thinking
ensuring full integration into the
research teaching learn
emissions of that organization of your
academic institution I know you know
specifics I won't i won't provide but at
a very high level the other thing that i
would think and again in terms of of
tracking entree via residences and
fellowships and this sort of thing a lot
of our member institutions are doing
this and i think it's a great service to
the profession but really ensuring that
if i may use the term legacy staffs of
those people who have been around a
little bit are are well informed about
what is happening well informed about
these trends well informed about what
the implications might be about how
those people with a diverse set of
experiences and what have you can
collaborate effectively together so i
think that's another critical point
there and then also providing us as
Krista said providing those professional
development experiences and also
encouraging people that to to be part of
the conversation to contribute to
professional organizations to contribute
to to the publication record to the
scholarly record within our context so I
think we've seen this issue of
difficulties with cohabitation and other
contexts within libraries think about
the baby boomers having to cohabit with
the Millennials is one thing the
professional staff versus the non
professional staff that that divide and
I think one of the things that's the the
real difficulty is this position of turf
and defining your pack who's in and
who's out Jim talks about being raised
by wolves but I think we also see folks
raised by coyotes and mountain lions and
many other kinds of predators out there
from my perspective I think the key
really is in interdependency I've been
thinking a lot about the liaison
functions in libraries lately and we
know the portfolios for liaisons have
continued to expand to meet new needs
and expectations
and it's clear that no one liaison can
do it all increasingly liaisons
typically falling I think into the camp
of the domain specialists are reliant on
functional experts to provide much
needed expertise in addressing the
strange and wonderful landscape of
research teaching and learning these
pairings provide for a stronger outreach
but they do raise turf issues should
subject expertise Trump functional skill
sets in reaching out to faculty and
students I there's a mutual dependence
between domain liaisons and functional
specialists but developing a mutual
model for working across functional
areas is a challenge interdependence has
yet to lead to an appreciation that
liaison work is important but individual
labels less so assigning a liaison
responsibility to teams instead of
individuals might be a good first step
one final point about this is that the
university is becoming increasingly
porous we see academic related functions
coming in and going out of libraries
centers for teaching excellence digital
humanities centers and the like
sometimes they come in and sometimes
they go out and those that ability to
work across those divides I think is
also key great I want to soon move into
questions and I hope and since there may
be a lot of good questions to ask but I
just had one left one last question
proposed to our group here and it's
already been alluded to a few times but
I think the question of mentorship
programs leadership programs fellowships
obviously has become you know these
would become more prominent and I would
wanted you to think a little bit about
and tell us how you see those fitting
into training either to replace
traditional degrees weather or
complement or in some cases replace
traditional degrees what do you think
we're getting from those that we can
in any other way and those kinds of
mentorship leadership programs mark
would you care to start us off sure I
think it's an interesting question
particularly within again the ARL
context and this transitioning that
we're going through to a new strategic
framework Carol referenced that earlier
and they's there's a particular
initiative an area called the ARL
Academy that really might play an
important role in in this type of
training but certainly as we look at our
own efforts in leadership development
also in mentoring and that sort of thing
there is lots of evidence that's that
this will support these transitions in
this transition of the workforce
providing opportunities mostly for for
those who go through those programs
especially in a cohort sort of
environment to connect with colleagues
in in in in ways that they really don't
have opportunities in other contexts so
i think that's that's really vital to
the work going forward i also think that
mentoring and coaching and those are two
really distinct roles but looking at
opportunities for coaching and and for
mentoring I i think is exciting and
particularly with respect to affecting
culture and training people about both
existing and aspirational cultures for
our organizations there's lots of
opportunity there and when we look to
our colleagues who are perhaps more
experienced and and and who have a
broader sense of of this they can impart
a lot of knowledge and really help with
those full integrations in into the
workforce so I'll just say a couple of
things because my colleagues here are
more better suited to respond to this
question but two things first I do think
that we need a greater emphasis placed
on post appointment training or
acculturation or credentialing or
whatever we want to call it I have a
great hope for new models that are
rising including the ARL academy that
mark referenced but as I think about new
folk
coming into the library at Cornell there
are three things that sort to the top
for me as I look at at new candidates
for the position are they collaborative
are they risk tolerant and are they
change ready it's only after thinking
through those things that I start to
place any real emphasis on the specific
degrees or qualifications that they have
frankly I'm a little degree agnostic it
means less to me what cards you carry
into the library but more what kinds of
skill sets and mindsets and and ability
to to continue to grow and develop
second I'm concerned about how future
professionals are being trained before
they come in into the library I think
libraries and I schools are doing a good
job of in parting theory but less so in
preparing for future professional work
in the workforce today Jim had raised in
his paper the notion of an executive MLS
I think it's an intriguing idea but I'd
also like to explore the idea of
coupling of library and high schools
with teaching research libraries much
like residency programs for MDS in
teaching hospitals these would have to
be I think closely aligned to career
paths and specializations rather than
general time in the trenches so maybe
you're interested in brain surgery or
pediatrics or the equivalent within the
library today any last comments right I
think that my colleagues have done a
great job so we can move on to questions
okay great great so we're going to I
know we stand between you and lunch but
we are going to just take a few moments
to take some questions and as a reminder
we have microphones on either end of the
room that we would ask you to use so
that we can hear you um you've talked a
lot about new new new hires new people
coming in etc let me just
set a little bit of a scenario for you
let's say I'm 45 haha don't I wish
anyway and I have a library degree and I
basically speak and read English and
have a limited knowledge of French and I
have done in my career probably seven or
eight hundred instruction sessions and
answered thousands of reference
questions and have done some faculty
liaison work and selected millions of
dollars worth of collections where do I
fit in the future what's my career path
what do I do now I mean I'm asking this
question on behalf of a lot of my
colleagues because whether we as library
administrators like it or not there are
a lot of people in our staff who are in
this position and what do you all
recommend that we consider as far as our
Human Resources policies and our
training and whatever because it's all
it's one thing when you're working with
somebody who's 29 it's another thing
when you're trying to encourage and
mentor somebody who's in their mid
career
I'll take a quick crack at it and then
hand it over quickly I think you have a
wonderful range of skill sets that are
being brought to the table I think in
some ways breaking out of sort of
traditional thinking about what those
skill sets can do and how they can be
put to play in greater partnerships with
faculty greater collaborations with
students sort of thinking more outside
in rather than inside out I'm always
amazed at how much faculty and students
think they know about things and then
how how limited that actually is one of
the area's we've been focusing on at
Cornell which I just love is this notion
of how to make academics and we've been
thinking a lot about doctoral students
more effective in their digital research
workflows and how do you put these
things together to to make it a more
effective thing that is appropriate to
your discipline and and one of the grad
students who just went through this
immersion program talked about I know
that I'd like to work with with
manuscripts and photographs but I also
acknowledge now that I'm a digital
worker and I need to be effective as a
digital worker and there's no excuse for
being unproductive in in that
environment so I think there's there's
some things that you can do in those new
forms of connections I was just going to
add that I i agree i think that the that
many of the core principles may be the
the if you get really granular a lot of
the work is changing but the core
principles are not changing so much
there's so many things that transfer
from one environmental from the analog
environment to the digital environment
and you really need to work at let fully
leveraging that I look at the University
of Kansas for example that really took
not a functional approach to
to reorganization they use the scallop
tool maybe Columbia has used it called
strengths finder as a method of inquiry
to figure out exactly where people's
interests were and and what their skills
were and where they wanted to be
developed and so they focused a
reorganization around that year long
exercise that I think many people at
that organization would find would
consider highly successful and many of
them transition to two positions that
they had not anticipated and so it
really has been good for the
organization I'll just say really
quickly that clear and EDUCAUSE
co-sponsor a program called the leading
change Institute and the purpose of that
is is just for the people such as you
describe for building a national network
of support for professionals who want to
advance sort of from the middle to do
something here we're going to have to
break for lunch and maybe you can ask we
have time for a question from region let
me let me just add one topic we haven't
addressed here in terms of the 21st
century a workforce is issues of
diversity and I've worked many many many
years with sponsorship and fundraising
for a la spectrum initiative to bring
more people from underrepresented
communities into the profession and his
mark knows I've worked very closely with
the LCD p program at ARL serving as a
mentor for I think five individuals in
that in that program over a 20-year
period data indicates that over the last
20 years we have not made significant
progress in diversifying our field do we
need to think about new strategies and
new approaches to diversifying our staff
whatever of whatever flavor if you will
and how what how are we going to do this
how are we going to solve this problem
it is a problem if I had the answer to
that question I'd be making a lot more
money
than I do right now however but i think
it's it's legitimate I do think again
are historically from a or else
perspective our strategies have been
focused on the MLIS and recruiting
people from very diverse racial and
ethnic backgrounds into the profession
but we have to cast the net more more
widely and get more of those fish I
think if we're going to remain relevant
if we're going to have people who can
curate collections that you know perhaps
you'll have have some some you know
sensitivity and that sort of thing in
terms of the content you looking at
perhaps I don't know I'm just making
this up right now a program similar to
the clear postdoctoral fellow that has a
diversity element to it or I focus on
diversity that sort of thing I think it
is critical however I mean if we go back
to the to the data we do have to keep
those efforts diversified because if
clearly if we can generalize it all from
from those data that i that i posted
earlier if fifty six percent of our
organizations fifty-six percent of those
position descriptions still require that
ml is we still need to keep our hand in
that bucket absolutely but in terms of
expanding our efforts absolutely we need
to find the capacity and or when is the
fundraising panel a little bit later
because we need to find the money also
to to support those endeavors as well
and hook them younger that's what i
would say it's not just the public
libraries responsibility to excite k-12
students with you know what the library
is and what it can be and what it can
bring to their lives well one last
comment recruitment one thing it's the
retention issue how do you really focus
on communities the ability to work
across things you know great minds think
alike but the flip is full seldom differ
and being able to tolerate different
perspectives at the table and different
work habits and and priorities i think
will be key moving forward I think with
that wheel turn to head to lunch thank
or please help me
palace